[Music]
you gotta face it folks we live in a
24-hour news cycle and there is so much
breaking news going on all the time it's
hard to process it all
well we here at the show we found a way
to put the day's news in perspective
with the help of one of our writers dion
cole watch this
well you probably heard this this week
baseball commissioner bud selick says
new allegations of steroid use could
force them to suspend up to 20 players
do you like watching home runs yeah
do steroids help players hit more home
runs well yeah i do but yeah i just
didn't think without steroids would
baseball be even slower and more boring
than what it is already yeah
but tailbone ceiling he need to just
play ball and shut the hell up
this week the supreme court ruled that
police can collect your dna if you're
arresting uh if you're arrested civil
liberties groups say that's an invasion
of privacy
can cops already take your fingerprints
yeah
has dna freed up a lot of brothers who
were falsely evicted yeah yeah it has
and look look look would you rather get
a cops your dna then rather have a cell
mate hold you down and they sell and
take your dna
yeah tell these people they need to shut
the hell up
finally this week taco bell fired an
employee who was photographed licking a
stack of taco shells despite the firing
some loyal customers say they'll never
eat a taco bell again
if you are a loyal taco bell customer
with sanitation ever your biggest
concern
now
[Applause]
and even licking those taco shells don't
you think they probably made them even
cleaner it's
it's possible yeah
well then they need to rehire the kid
make a manager and tell everybody to
shut them
[Applause]
by the way ladies and gentlemen very
exciting dion's launching his own comedy
show right here on tbs isn't that right
dion
that is right conan
they gave me my own show called dionko's
black box
this is straight up funny look at tv pop
culture on the internet and it's all
coming from the point of view of this
black man all right that sounds great
if you don't believe me
[Applause]
isn't just for young black viewers it's
for anyone who enjoys laughing at funny
things
[Applause]
the uncle's black box premieres monday
at 10 pm check it out